i would say religious and ethnic
conflicts an enormous force in a very
negative sense i'm a christian but if
you look at how many wars have been
fought over christianity and we see
today be in the Muslim world in the
Jewish world I'm very very concerned
about this and I think it's had a very
negative force and I think it's a
tragedy that people of faith and people
who are people believe tend to separate
today rather than use that to bring
people together and the fact we've gone
off in so many different directions and
we look at people of different belief
sets as evil and some of this you can
see in an African tribal setting you can
see it here in the United States and in
various recruit groups proselytizing for
their set of beliefs and actually
looking for enemies and setting people
off almost like Satan and the devil and
I think this has been extremely damaging
in society and has cost us many many
wars and and you know millions of lives